你总是手脚冷冷吗
小心喔
有一种手脚冰冷最危险
那就是
可能血流就是被卡住了
甚至是中风
或者是心肌梗塞的前兆
你常常敲「十宣穴」
血液流通
顺顺的时候呢
双手就会暖暖的
它又有降血压
预防头晕的效果喔
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
冬天时你总是手脚都会冷冷的
小心喔
有一种手脚冰冷最危险
就是单侧的手
单侧的脚冰冷
当你发现手或脚
只有一边持续冰冷
麻麻的没力气
可不能疏忽
可能就是血流被卡住了
甚至于是中风或
心肌梗塞的前兆
不要拖赶紧去找医生
给你检查吧
尤其这三种人更要小心
超过50岁的
有糖尿病的
有心血管疾病的
手脚老是冰冷
可能是血液循环出问题
长期下来
也会引发
手脚麻木
伤口难愈合
甚至于
中风或者是
心肌梗塞
手脚冰冷原来这么严重
我都不知道
手脚冰冷是什么原因
手脚冰冷是什么体质
有这两个原因
第一个是体质偏寒
就是你一吹到风
就觉得
寒冷喔
第二个就是血量不足或贫血
中医称之为血虚
就是脸色苍白
四肢都会冷冰冰的
手脚冰冷怎么改善呢
马上跟你说
早晚敲敲手30下
暖手脚降血压
手脚冷冰冰的时候
除了把手伸到
另外一半的口袋里去
我教你有一个
不求人又有效的方法
那就是敲十宣穴
你常常敲十宣穴
血液流通顺顺的时候
双手就会暖暖的
它又有
降血压预防头晕的效果
十宣穴在哪里呢
在手指尖
就是十个手指的尖端的前方
叫做十宣穴
这些地方离心脏最远
血液循环
最容易卡卡的
我知道我知道
是不是这样敲
对我美丽的太太就是这样
她每天都在那敲敲敲
自己在家里都可以这样敲
把你的双手手心相对
手指弯曲
左手和右手的指尖就这样子
咚咚咚咚
敲它个30次
分早上晚上
各敲大概15下也就够了
还不需要敲很多
还有一种敲法
就是让血液循环更快的加速
就是和你的另一半
和你的美丽的太太敲起来
就这样子敲
就这样敲
OK
刚才手都冰冰的
现在敲一敲
我的手都温暖了
那很赞啊
十宣穴它是
十个指头气血交会的地方
能帮助你通调阴阳开窍
能够醒神
临床上
我会用十宣穴急救
中风的昏迷的人
帮助血液重新分布
我曾经就有过一个病人
我在医院里头看这个病人
另外一床的病人竟然的
中风的现象出现了
他的太太叫我说
你能不能来看一看
我一看中风
马上在这个地方
放了一点血
立刻恢复了
3个部位不能受寒
敲腿1处去寒防掉发
天冷了
有伴的人
最幸福的是莫过于
有人帮你盖被子
没伴的人
我们也要把自己
穿得够
穿得暖暖的
多爱自己一点
人家有男友力
我有保暖力
明明穿很多
为什么身体一直觉得冷
你检查一下这三个地方
有没有包得紧紧的
第一脚底
第二颈部
第三腹部
脚底是第一个要保暖好的部位
喜欢穿短袜短裙
爱露美腿的小姐
你知道吗
我们的双脚
是全身阳气的发源地
腿把它裸露出来
寒风直接吹进身体里头
阳气迅速的散失
这个时候
会发生什么问题呢
寒邪就从脚
就从腿入侵了
导致手脚冰冷
血液循环差
还可能引发
关节疼痛
关节酸痛
年轻的时候为了爱美
年老的时候出现关节痛
可不划算啰
你还是选一条保暖的裤子
袜子呢选一双厚袜子
让脚踝到小腿的地方
都能够保暖留住阳气
我待会还会教你
如何拍肾经
第二个是颈部
脖子有个风池穴风府穴
这几个地方呢
那个风最容易从这个地方进去
于是呢一进去了
那个风那个寒
血压马上往上飙高
你可以围一条围巾
来挡住风寒
第三是腹部
天气太冷
你知道吗
交感神经就会影响到肠胃
造成蠕动发生问题
让你容易泻肚子
女生呢很容易经痛
我们出门的时候
这样的时候
就要把脖子
围巾围好
肚子就要给它
不要露出来
不要让人看到
不是不要看
袜子也要穿得厚
没错我教你一个
脚底暖起来的方法
就是拍肾经
它能够改善循环
身体暖起来
还能够防止掉发哦
肾经就是在脚踝的附近
这个地方呢
有三个穴位非常重要
复溜穴照海穴太溪穴
怎么敲呢
你把手握成一个拳头
从复溜穴由上往下
这样敲到照海穴
然后呢
再从下往上
敲到太溪穴上
来敲 敲敲就这样子敲一敲
一天来回它个
三五次就可以了
来先找到复溜穴
它在小腿的内侧
内踝尖上两寸
脚那个跟腱的前方一点点
复溜穴能够通经活络消水肿
关节不好
容易水肿的人
都可以常常在这里
按一按敲一敲
再找到太溪穴
太溪穴呢
是在内踝的后方
一个凹陷的地方
它是补肾的重要的穴道哦
肾经的原动力都在这个地方
你会手脚冰冷
腰膝酸软的人啊
都常常敲一敲太溪穴
可以保护这个肾
最后照海穴
照海穴呢
它在内踝的下方
前面一点点凹陷之处
敲它能够改善健忘
失眠头发干燥
还能让你不那么怕冷
那什么时间敲效果最好呢
在肾经最旺的时候
最旺的时候是
下午五点到七点
下午五点到七点哦
还有七点到九点的时候
也可以再来补一下啦
那上班的人
中午的时间敲一敲
这样可以吗
当然可以啊
为什么不行呢
就是我讲台语
就是说
有拍到就有保佑啦
不是保佑啦
那就是
有拍到就有保佑嘛
有敲到就有保佑嘛
穿厚袜脚底还是冷
1张纸脚快速升温
怕冷的人他都穿羊毛袜
脚又冷冷的
晚上又睡不着怎么办
那如何让脚底变暖
我跟你说
有一个方法很省钱
你只要把一张纸
放在鞋子里面
就能够让脚底变温暖啰
什么纸这么厉害啊
就是铝箔纸
蛤铝箔纸可以保暖吗
可以
你拿一张铝箔纸
把亮面朝上
包覆住脚掌的前端
再穿拖鞋
脚底就能够瞬间升温
据说穿鞋子的时候
能升温到
8度
为什么
因为铝箔纸的亮面
导热效果非常的好
能把你的脚跟温暖
迅速传到脚趾上面去
这是一个日本自然疗法的名医
叫川嶋朗他的实验
他是专门研究怕冷体质的医学博士
今晚睡前你就可以试一试
你还有其他的保暖妙招吗
留言给我们分享
大家来互相取暖
5种发热食物
手脚暖翻天
手脚冰冷要吃什么来改善呢
我们前面提到了
血虚型的手脚冰冷的人
你可以吃五种食物
羊肉红枣肉桂姜韭菜
来我教你怎么吃
我们先说羊肉
最棒的吃法就是煮成
我知道
当归生姜羊肉汤
对不对
当然对了
答案非常肯定
你煮给爸爸妈妈先生小孩
各来一碗
吃羊肉能够补肌肉的气
当归补血生姜活血
吃完身体就暖呼呼的
促进血液循环
你自己也要记得来一碗哦
全家一起增强免疫能力
让脸颊的气血都红通通的
当归生姜羊肉汤
药食两用皆宜
堪称药物之精
医方之祖
你有这种经验吗
冬天的时候
因为寒风吹到肚子里头
结果导致肚子剧烈的疼痛
我们中医界有一个神级的人物
叫做张仲景
被称之为医圣
他用当归生姜羊肉汤
让这种问题的人服用
结果你知道怎么样了
病人只吃两次
肚子就不痛了
身体也温暖了
效果是很赞哦
第二个就是红枣
月经量少
手脚冰冷
容易累的妹妹们
可以喝什么
你可以泡一杯
红枣姜茶
或红枣桂圆茶
红枣能够补血又补气
它会让你那种
虚的发冷的寒气
慢慢的就散掉了
气血循环变得顺畅
第三是姜
你炒菜煮汤等等的时候
放一点姜就很好
姜能活血散寒
外食也可以点一个咖喱饭来吃
咖喱里面还有姜黄
能够暖身又能够抗发炎
第四个是肉桂
肉桂很厉害哦
它很厉害的功效是什么呢
就是引肾气归于元
也就是归到肾里面去了
是什么意思呢
就是保护肾气不会外散
增强全身的暖意
寒性体质的人
吃了手脚就暖
第五个是韭菜
有一句话说一月葱二月韭
在农历二月的时候
吃韭菜最能补肾
把阳气一路带到手脚
改善冰冷的体质
好我等一下要去菜市场
把这些菜都买回来